Carol I want to play a clip you were on
Jordan Peterson's podcast about a week
ago and you guys got into why it's
important to fight the culture wars and
why certain people don't and why certain
people do I think that's definitely
related to what's going on here in
Florida take a look
conservatives are so damn blind that
this goes up on under their noses
constantly and they often facilitate its
movement forward
and it's because they're they're either
ignorant that's part of the problem or
they're afraid on the moral front and
neither of those are excusable
especially when hypothetically they're
concerned about losing the cultural War
which they are definitely losing well
look at the abuse and pushback that
Governor DeSantis gets even from other
Republicans you know people that are in
the public eye the the Chris Christie's
of the world and such they say things
like he DeSantis Sparks cultural Wars
well culture wars are really important
because a war for the culture matters
culture matters so yes we should be
fighting these wars I think so much of
what we talk about is
um dismissed by the left and we let them
dismiss it we let them say oh this
doesn't matter but it does matter and we
should be talking about it all the time
I think that the schools and the fight
for our schools is so important
Pedro took to Carol's point and to
Jordan's Point MSNBC right now and
Donald Trump and Mike Pence and Chris
Christie and Nikki Haley are all on the
same side of Disney against DeSantis
right now all DeSantis did was even the
playing field he got rid of crony
capitalism which apparently the leftists
and now Trump are for it's incredible
actually
yeah it's not only incredible but it's
also in order to do this Trump has to
repudiate his own position as as the
culture Warrior right the one who was
saving us from the extremes the left
he's now rooting for Disney and I think
that's that's problematic for two
reasons one like you and this is the
point that I actually keep highlighting
uh because I think it's it's powerful
and it cuts across both aisles and
that's that really this is this is as
much it is a culture War thing obviously
like Disney was pushing these radical
ideas
um on kids through their programming but
it's also a question of who rules
are corporations above any
accountability right do they get to say
do they get to do whatever they want
because I think you have to go back here
and remember that this started with the
um the the parental rights and Education
Act Right which was really popular in
Florida for obvious reasons and Disney
was not happy with it and basically said
you know we don't care that Floridians
like this bill uh that protects families
from from the extreme to the left we're
going to do everything in our power to
to to kill it and if it passes we're
going to we're going to basically engage
in economic Warfare against politicians
by by withholding donations
from from people that have basically
Been instrumental to Disney's success
right so there's no kind of there's no
sense of humility from the company and
so DeSantis said no actually
corporations don't get to do whatever
they want Floridians are actually in
charge of their own State and Disney
doesn't get to push around the the
entire state government
and I think I think when you frame it
like that what Trump and Haley and Pence
are doing becomes even more disgusting
they're siding with a corporation that
basically has said like we rule not you
the people of Florida right there and
the funny part the interesting part is
so DeSantis is going against the
corporations I thought the left-hated
corporations he's going against the
donor class which is not happy I thought
politicians weren't supposed to be owned
by donors and he went from winning his
first election by 30 000 votes to 1.6
million so he's clearly doing what the
people want